just another normal day this is our
let's a daily or Dean when they're not
running for cover workers at histol
about eight kilometers north of Gaza
help so and sell 600 million vegetable
plants a year while we were huddled in
the bomb shelter a short while ago a
rocket actually hit this nursery if you
look here this is what's left of a tamia
missile from Israel's Iron Dome missile
defense system it crashed through the
roof just here knocking out a tray of
budding pepper plants and all that's
left at least here of the militants
rocket is this CEO amit duggan says it's
business as usual but that doesn't mean
they're not affected
every time we have this tyrant the
people's have to run to the shelters
it's a lot of time that is spent on
running and coming back to work we have
to stop all the machines and run them
again there was a lot of damage to the
cover of the green of this net a
polyethylene that have to be fixed or
replaced after each mrs. or in shrapnel
hit it further south muggins men and
women are making solar water heaters
Gaza is just four and a half kilometres
west the quarter of the workers are
absent called up to the army or home
caring for kids who summer camps can't
open because of the fighting CEO Mattie
bubbly says the factory hasn't closed in
40 years it's not about to start now the
noises don't move and the situation is
not the pleasure to be here but we have
to satisfy our customers involved the
customer in Australia in the u.s. is not
interested if there is a war here or not
the war shows no sign of ending soon so
this is the third time these sirens have
gone since we've been here we're heading
to our third shelter Israeli companies
can't ignore it but they carry on
regardless Elliot got can Bloomberg
Ashkelon southern Israel